[Applause]
we have a little bit of time left um
enough for one question so we were gonna
do one quick drew and a
um does anyone have a question i know
i'm throwing this at you but spontaneity
is kind of the point would anyone like
to ask me a question
the gentleman in the colorful jacket i
mean i mean i i am picking up what you
are putting down sir
what is your name aaron pessen and where
are you from brooklyn brooklyn new york
i love your colorful ways they're just i
feel like you're a walking billboard of
joy i'm a professional clown so i i like
to bring are you serious
[Applause]
what's your question erin what would be
your dream acting role that you've
always wanted to do that you haven't
done yet
i guess you know i'd like to make a film
with adam sandler when we're really old
[Applause]
we've talked a lot about like doing an
on golden pond type of movie we both
love lakes
um
and uh we could just live on the lake
and and be old together and
that would that would that would be a
dream role for me my dream role right
now is this
i
like
no joke
well thank you all
so much
um for being here we make this show for
you so
take it with you and thank you for
choosing to spend your time with us
and maybe we'll see you soon
[Music]
you